open c there were allegations yesterday
uh that the head of product who i don't
know uh from everything i understand the
people at openc are fantastic this is
not necessarily a story about openc
specifically but about how the
blockchain changes the way that business
is done
but there was an allegation that the
head of product was basically front
running nft drops on the main page so
what would happen from my understanding
is they would go and they were about to
do an nft drop on the front page but
people on the website couldn't actually
see it yet because it wasn't published
and then this person would go and they
would buy some of them uh they would
hold on to them they would do the drop
prices would start to rise and then that
person would take the nfts and then sell
it to the public obviously not good if
it's true there was a um let's pull up
the tweet first and on the tweet the
part to me that just blew my absolute
mind here
is that this person
zuvu
tv on twitter
who by the way when you click on the
profile just says internet person which
i love
said hey at openc why does it appear the
header product has a few secret wallets
that appears to buy your front page
drops before they are listed then sells
them shortly after the front page hype
spike for profits and then tumbles them
back to his main wallet with his punk on
it
and then what they essentially did is
they went through and looked on
etherscan and found the transactions and
so this is an absolute game changer
because now what you have are millions
of people around the world on the
internet who are able to audit
the blockchain and so they're able to
see here is a wallet address here's
where they're sending the value here is
where the uh the money is going and
they're watching the flow of capital on
a blockchain and so this is one example
just happens to be the one that happened
uh overnight
but this is the difference between the
two systems how many times has there
been front running in the legacy system
and nobody knew about it or it took
years for folks to figure it out this is
literally a pseudo anonymous account on
twitter somebody figured it out and then
they go and then in true internet
fashion literally just tweet about it
and they say hey what's going on here
and they're trying to hide and they're
tagging the person they're attacking the
company and they put it out and
obviously the tweet went viral etc but
then the beauty of it is not only did
they use the public blockchain to figure
it out then they published their work
they literally said hey i don't know
maybe i'm missing something if i'm
missing something i'm happy to say that
i'm wrong by the way here's the
transactions here's literally what i
looked at and they screenshotted it they
posted the links etc and they included
the wallet addresses and all this stuff
and so to me this is absolutely crazy
how the world changes now once you have
these public open blockchains like this
and then we can see that there was a um
a blog post published by
openc today
and what they essentially said you know
it's disappointing they want it clear
that this behavior does not represent
the values of the team they're taking it
seriously they're conducting uh kind of
a review of the incident uh so they can
make sure that they understand all the
facts and what additional steps need to
be taken important i actually this is a
huge uh kudos to open c saying hey we
hear you we're gonna go do the work
we're not just gonna bend the knee to
the mob and just immediately go and and
take action we want to understand what
happened very important in today's
environment the fact that they are
willing to conduct the review before
they actually go and take the action uh
and they've also implemented new
policies things like team members not
being able to buy or sell from
collections or creators while they're
featured or promoting them uh and also
team members are prohibited from using
confidential information to purchase or
selling enfts when available in the
openc platform or not i tend to think
that these new policies uh generally are
like good i don't think many people are
like oh that's that's a bad idea um and
on top of that i think that um
you start to understand there is a
entire world of um kind of maturation
that's going to happen in these markets
right if this was equities this would
obviously be insider trading it would be
illegal there would be huge issues uh
people would not be happy you know
whatever um but the fact that it's these
nfts i think it's going to call into
question you know regulators are gonna
start peeking over and saying hey how do
we treat this stuff and i don't know if
there's answers yet yeah i think look
when you open up an entirely new market
there's gonna be bad actors wherever you
go and this just opens up a new area for
people to go do that in a different
realm so whether it's uh kind of here on
the nft platform we saw it with litecoin
the other day when they got uh the press
release that went viral and kind of the
price pump 20
i'm sure whoever was putting that
information out there profited off the
the price increasing that much uh and so
forth and these are just two examples
there's hundreds and thousands of others
of people doing similar uh kind of
things that are illegal or bad acting or
whatever it is i mean like the the openc
thing the press release is all right i
think that's like kind of like uh you
know customary at this point of like hey
we're gonna go figure out what happened
um i don't necessarily know if they
should get credit for saying hey we're
gonna go find the facts uh because that
would be like the baseline of what they
should do but look the guys that had a
product so it's obviously a big deal uh
it's an emerging platform he's clearly
doing things that users found out that
were illegal or not right uh but i think
at the end of the day what we're gonna
see is this blockchain and this
technology has enabled people uh and the
internet specifically has enabled people
to find these things and back in the day
uh even before the internet and all the
other technology that has come over the
past 20 25 years this wasn't possible
right so as we open up these new markets
the ability for people to get caught has
also opened so i think we'll uh we'll
continue to see uh bad actors just like
we would anywhere else but i think we'll
also continue to see that that uh that
possibility that you're not gonna get
caught is gonna shrink because of public
ledgers like the blockchain and so forth
i have a hard time like i understand or
would understand it more if this was
like a low-level employee at openc but
the head of product should know better
oh i don't think anyone
there's two there's two perspectives to
take here one is of ignorance and one is
of malice uh
right i i tend to my initial reaction is
always i don't know the individual i
don't know all the facts and so i'm
gonna go with ignorance not malice to
start
oh i reserve the right to change my mind
later and say hey you know this was
really you know intentional and
malicious but again it goes back to what
we're just talking about like why is
somebody doing this for profit
right like the only reason why you would
go when you would get the nfts hold them
wait for the price to go up and then
sell them is because you're trying to
profit yeah he was buying them right
before they got put on the public page
and promoted and then selling them right
after once the price went out which
which to be fair
every single person waiting for that
drop
if they had the opportunity to front run
they would do it
right if all of a sudden they could
figure out how to get a faster internet
connection and they could basically get
the drop before everybody else they
would absolutely do it so there is a
element of
um
doing the activity in order to gain an
advantage
there is an ethical boundary right where
it's okay you want to get a faster
internet so that you can get it like in
gaming right take esports for example i
was talking to somebody in the esports
world they said a lot of people are
moving to texas or trying to live in the
middle of the country and the reason is
that when they play these esports games
if somebody's in florida and then
they're playing somebody somewhere else
and their team is spread out there can
actually be lag between the players so
they do they try to all go move together
but there's the difference between
trying to gain i think that was i think
what happened again unethical hold on a
second so what i'm saying is people are
constantly looking for an edge right in
the stock market people will move their
servers as close to the stock exchange
service as possible so there's low
latency et cetera that's not what we're
talking about here so it's not just hey
nobody should have an advantage right
there's things that fall within the
ethical boundaries that they say look
that's part of what people are trying to
do is they're trying to get insider
trading is trading on material
non-public information that's exactly
what this was it so i don't actually
think it's going to fall under insider
no no i don't agree that it'll fall
under that law and i don't necessarily
know if he even did anything illegal i
think it was just john's point it looks
shady it's probably a little unethical
but my point more generally is when you
sign up to be the chief product officer
at ubc this is my point you are you're
knowing that you're not allowed to do
stuff like that if you're a user of the
platform and you're trying to get a
faster internet connection to get an
edge on the drop or something all is low
you know all is fair in love and war
yeah but when the second you become an
employee the rules change right you're
no longer in a position where you can do
those types of things that's my point is
it's not so much that uh
people aren't doing this already trying
to get an age on the drops literally the
whole point of the drop is hey we're
gonna go we're gonna drop a bunch of
nfts all at once and then there's like a
mad scramble of people trying to get
them of course people are gonna try to
do stuff to get an advantage but when
you're an employee you can't do that i
am not i do not know what happened right
i was not with him when he did it um i
do not know if he if he actually did
like
that
john was with them john was in the room
people people say stuff all the time uh
if unless someone proved to me through
the blockchain which i have not seen
personally uh that this happened i have
no ill feelings right like
basically innocent until proven guilty
in my eyes and uh the eyes of the court
but i think if this happened this is
super unethical super shady um he should
definitely be removed from the company
and oh you think fired i 100
i mean it comes down to a loss of trust
right yeah and the other thing that i'll
say here is again to kind of hammer home
this point if somebody was trying to uh
get in on the drop and they wrote a bot
and that bot basically executed at a
nanosecond to purchase we would all say
damn i wish i had the ability to write
the bot but they just they beat me to it
right and we could be upset about it but
no one would be like that's unethical
well people the second it's an employee
then that's when the issues come in
people have bots
for sneakers right when they drop
no one complains about that i'm not
saying that that is on bro they spent
billions of dollars to increase the
speed uh at which trade gets trades get
executed at the new york stock exchange
they built a fiber optic cable across
half the country yes just to have a
little bit of an edge i'm not saying
that having an edge is wrong i'm saying
when you have an edge that no one else
can build or has
then when you're an employee yeah hey
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
software.compomp and make sure you come
back and watch more the best business
show we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help
[Music]